[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
con nuestros periodistas invitados
conversamos sobre algunos de los hechos
más destacados de la semana Este
programa es el espacio para que los
periodistas puedan dar su opinión
libremente Comenten sus puntos de vista
sobre los temas de la actualidad de el
mundo Bueno pues para conversar sobre
los temas que hemos seleccionado para el
día de hoy saludamos en el estudio de
France 24 a Juan barreto él es
periodista jefe de fotografía para
Colombia de la agencia France Juan
Bienvenido al programa y cómo termina su
semana Hola buenas tardes
bueno bien una semana llena de mucho
movimiento
mucha noticia No ahora buscando
información buscando cosas que comenzar
a hacer no de cosas comenzar a hacer en
nuestro trabajo
perfecto pues bienvenido al programa
Juan también está con nosotros Perla
Pineda reportera geopolítica del
periódico El economista Perla qué tal
termina usted su semana Bienvenida al
programa
pues muchas gracias Pues al igual que el
compañero en Colombia Pues esta fuente
que es muy activa pues ya preparándonos
también para el fin de semana qué más
puede seguir saliendo
efectivamente el fin de semana también
se generan muchísimas noticias vamos a
ver qué nos trae este fin de semana
Entonces con qué nos sorprende también
saludo a Francisco belaúnde periodista
del Canal TV Perú noticias Francisco
Bienvenido al programa y cómo termina
usted su semana
bien Bueno también con muchas han
ocurrido muchas cosas no solamente tanto
en el Perú que siempre ocurren cosas
Últimamente como en el mundo pero
precisamente no así que bueno semana
agitada bueno pues le recuerdo que
ustedes también nos pueden acompañar con
todas sus preguntas y comentarios a
través de las redes sociales estamos
como arroba France 24 guión bajo ese
arroba santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral una
semana en el mundo entremos en materia
Entonces esta semana parte de la
atención internacional sin duda alguna
pasó por la ciudad de Washington la
capital de Estados Unidos debido a la
visita oficial de estado del presidente
francés Emanuel majó quien se reunió con
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden se trató de una visita necesaria
para reforzar las relaciones Franco
estadounidenses que se habían enfriado
un poco digamoslo así al ser anunciado
ese tratado aucus un tratado firmado
entre Australia el Reino Unido y Estados
Unidos que dejó por fuera a Francia
ambos países se mostraron Unidos en
temas Como por ejemplo la otan la
defensa europea la Guerra de Ucrania el
mejoramiento en su entendimiento En
temas comerciales y también en esta
decisión de ambos países de competir
frente a frente contra china en esta
nueva carrera espacial que se ha
desatado en los últimos meses
pues le doy entonces la palabra a Perla
Comencemos por las por las mujeres del
panel para conocer las opiniones Perla
Pues aquí en France 24 no solamente
porque se trataba el presidente francés
que estaba de visita en Washington pero
era una visita de trascendencia
internacional lo que se hablaba en la
casa blanca a lo largo de esta semana
tenía eco en diferentes rincones del
planeta importante ver a Estados Unidos
y a Francia con una relación bastante
estrecha un mensaje muy claro para el
resto del mundo cómo lo vio usted Perla
Sí Santiago Pues justo digo parada en
que fue la primera visita de estado que
recibió durante esta pandemia y bueno
con el antecedente de que había
fricciones por el tema comercial justo
no eh vaiden le tira una cuenta y muy
importante de buques a Francia pues era
muy esperada además de Pues en el
contexto que se está dando de Ucrania y
bueno Además de que pues este tema a
final de cuentas los les permitió como
de cierta manera realinear nuevamente
sus agendas
pues se pueden ver como te puedo ver
pues como ya lo independientemente de
que ellos lo dijeron Pues que fue una
conversación muy amena y pues que a
final de cuentas muy amigable no y que a
final de cuentas pues reencamina estos
dos países para hacer puente justo en el
contexto de la guerra en Rusia y Ucrania
y pasó a preguntarle entonces a
Francisco también por sus impresiones
sobre este tema el eco que esto puede
también tener de América Latina y el eco
que ha tenido en los medios de
comunicación a mí me llamó mucho la
atención por ejemplo ver que los medios
de Estados Unidos no le dieron mucha
trascendencia a Esta visita y poco
cubrimiento le dieron en los diferentes
publicaciones y en los medios de
televisión y en radio
bueno
es una visita importante
extranjero en visita de estado que es
más importante con una visita de trabajo
todo lo demás no y que las relaciones
entre Francia y Estados Unidos son muy
antiguas
que ayudó a Estados Unidos en su
independencia pero son aliados muy
antiguos pero efectivamente Hay muchas
discrepancias en particular
no el tema de Afganistán
que fue mal manejado por Estados Unidos
que fue criticado por los europeos y y
lo último no la ley de contra contra la
inflación que tiene un paquete de ayuda
para la fabricación en Estados Unidos en
particular de carros eléctricos de
baterías Qué significan que el temor
para no solamente para Francia
europea es que en muchos inversionistas
prefieran no trasladar sus inversiones a
Estados Unidos porque tienen esa ventaja
competitiva de recibir dinero del estado
por supuesto más poniendo en cuestión el
tema de la las reglas del comercio
internacional no entonces el tema está
qué va a pasar ahí qué va a pasar ahí y
cuál va a ser la respuesta no ha seguido
yo muy amable
Bueno vamos
tenemos ahí un problemilla técnico con
la conexión de Francisco vamos a a
retomarla con el equipo técnico de acá
del estudio para para retomar esa
conexión continuó Mientras tanto con
Juan aquí en el estudio de France 24
también abordando el mismo tema
impresiones de de esta de Esta visita
esa foto
ese momento ese saludo entre biden y
macron tiene eco a nivel internacional
demanda un mensaje muy claro a la Unión
Europea a Rusia a Ucrania y sobre todo a
China también en temas comerciales claro
a nivel de imagen es importantísimo es
importantísimo Mostrar que que hay una
Unión o que hay una relación entre
Estados Unidos Francia y como imagen es
súper importante no Y si eso da a
mostrar que que hay una en este caso al
gobierno de Rusia o al gobierno o a
Ucrania que están es muy importante para
para ver si eso queda termina en algún
momento no sí el mensaje es muy claro
torno a esa Alianza y lo insisto esto
tiene eco en la otan tiene eco también
en la Unión Europea ese encuentro además
que Perla aquí se nos dio la verdadera
sensación lo comentaba yo con algunos
compañeros de acá de la redacción que a
pesar de que la relación entre Francia
Estados Unidos no estaba pasando por su
mejor momento si parece que sí hay muy
buenas relaciones entre los dos
presidentes macron ibai parece llevarse
muy bien y tener un canal de diálogo
bastante fluido por lo menos eso es lo
que notamos nosotros desde acá Cuál es
su impresión
Sí este
Más allá de lo que de los comunicados o
sea Sí se nota que hay intención
compromiso de los dos mandatarios por
retomar tanto la relación bilateral de
llevarla a un mejor nivel Y pues también
para hacer puente no a nivel mundial no
Sí se ve un claro ejemplo de que
intentan resincronizar sus agendas no Y
bueno pues este a final de cuentas
Francia tiene que abrir espacios en
otras partes del mundo pues para buscar
la paz que justo intenta impulsar en
este conflicto ruso ucraniano
y Francisco le preguntó por esas esas
cargas de Liderazgo está Estados Unidos
también tratando de mantener esa imagen
de país líder de potencia líder pero que
hay de del presidente macron y ese
liderazgo que se le ha ido
entregando digamoslo así a nivel europeo
una vez terminó su mandato La cancillera
alemana Ángela Merkel la ha tomado un
poco esas riendas de Liderazgo europeo
esto lo evidencia Cuál es su impresión
bueno
él ha querido definitivamente desde el
inicio de su mandato él ha querido hacer
un liderazgo en Europa Claro en un
momento estaba Ángela Merkel no entonces
sabía efectivamente
su mandato este siempre ha querido
mantener
adelante Francisco continúe adelante
en esta visita a Estados Unidos Pues de
una manera lo está haciendo no quiere va
a regresar probablemente un poco
decepcionado Es verdad que tiene una
relación personal con baile muy buena
pero vaya no va a ceder la ley se
mantiene norteamericana más bien van a
tratar de llegar a un acuerdo en la
ejecución de la ley que le puede dejar
espacios a Europa para mitigar los
efectos que su pudiera tener a las
inversiones que no se vayan a ir todas
hacia Estados Unidos y el miedo está
perdida No de de peso industrial de
Europa por esta por esta esta ley
norteamericana
importante Francisco ese punto que usted
resalta ahí en su intervención vamos a
pasar ahora a América Latina dejamos de
lado este tema de la visita del
presidente macoa a Estados Unidos una
visita que concluyó justamente con la
presencia de el presidente francés en el
estado de Luisiana que recordemos es un
estado que perteneció a Francia fue
vendido a los Estados Unidos en un
momento de la historia entonces pues
tiene cierto
representatividad histórica que el
presidente esté visitando nueva
orleansia algunas poblaciones cercanas
justamente Allí se estaba reuniendo con
algunos ciudadanos estadounidenses que
son francófonos con lengua materna
tienen el francés Es muy representativo
ese aspecto cultural de ese estado en el
sur de Estados Unidos otro tema
destacado de la semana sin duda alguna
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador que celebró ya sus cuatro
años de gobierno con una marcha
multitudinaria y también un discurso en
el Zócalo de Ciudad de México la capital
amlo destacó 110 logros alcanzados
durante su administración frente a miles
de asistentes y también resaltó el
aumento de aspectos Como por ejemplo el
20% en el salario mínimo
Indicó que pese a la inflación no
aumentó el precio de los combustibles
cosa que sí pasó en otros países de
América Latina y también destacó el
aumento de los puestos de trabajo a lo
largo de su gestión también hay algunos
temas que quedan todavía como en deuda
en falta por ejemplo la seguridad y la
lucha contra los cárteles de la droga y
también ese posicionamiento de México a
nivel internacional o posicionamiento en
algo más que un liderazgo regional un
liderazgo a nivel de América Latina que
todavía sigue siendo una deuda pendiente
por lo menos en materia de política
exterior paso a preguntarle por supuesto
a Perla en México sus impresiones sobre
esta este discurso está multitudinaria
manifestación y esté
altísimo de popularidad que tiene el
presidente entre los mexicanos
Sí pues este justo cayó esta
marcha multitudinaria y pues su informe
de gobierno contra digamos también
contra una contra marcha no
respecto a la reforma del INE y
efectivamente como tú dices Man amlo
mantiene
puestos niveles todavía de aceptación
pero sin embargo va a seguir enfrentando
la polarización del país no y bueno
hablo pues destacó y reiteró su bandera
No que los pobres son primero eh justo
enfatizando en sus programas sociales
tú también ya lo mencionaste
implícitamente dejó Claro que la mejor
política exterior es la mejor es la
política interior y efectivamente pues
no podemos ver mucho de política
exterior Deja que ver mucho todavía el
mandatario en este tema
de izquierda justo que es el gobierno de
izquierda primero en México y pues a ver
veremos ya después de que Silva tome
posesión en enero del próximo año Pues a
ver cómo se estas izquierdas Ahora sí
van a pelear por el la presencia en la
región
y cuál es la opinión por acá en el
estudio de Juan sobre este estos cuatro
años del presidente mexicano que que
deja en materia positiva él lo ha
resaltado obviamente él Será su informe
pero también hay varias deudas
pendientes Cuál es su perspectiva Bueno
a nivel de de lo que hago que es imagen
que lo que yo me preparé este veo a
López Obrador y me hace acordar tanto el
inicio de desde el gobierno de Chávez
del 99 yo este me tocó desde el 99 hasta
el momento de su muerte y hay tantas
similitud sabes popularidad en la gente
como lo seguía en cada manifestación
cada marcha mucho más ahorita cuando vi
las imágenes en su de la marcha que hizo
hace un par de días y veía el Zócalo
lleno de gente y me acordé tanto en esa
esa manifestación que hacía Hugo Chávez
en Caracas en la avenida Bolívar que
llenaba y llenaba la cantidad de gente y
también me tocó mucho también cubrir
Fidel Castro cuando cuando antes de su
muerte que me tocó hacer mucho su
discurso en la Habana y es igual veo
como como la cantidad de gente como
llama la cantidad de gente y es lo mismo
cambias el personaje o cambia el momento
no pero pero a nivel de lo que causan a
lo que a su pueblo a lo que yo gente a
lo que ellos creen que que lo siguen es
lo mismo sabes que cumple o no cumpla es
parte de del pueblo no usted estuvo en
esas manifestaciones estuvo en esas
demostraciones
Cómo cómo es cuál puede ser ese ese
instrumento mágico digámoslo Así que le
permite generar esa conexión con el
pueblo tan fácilmente que Tal parece que
el presidente mexicano también lo tiene
para conectarse con el pueblo es el
discurso es la forma de entregar ese
discurso es la forma de aproximarse con
la gente usted que lo ha visto desde
diferentes personajes Bueno yo lo que
creo Es que también esto la gente cree
en algo porque lo que estaban
anteriormente fallaron no el que no
cumple no cumplió nunca y sale alguien
un poco de de Esperanza política
económica y Esperanza al pueblo la gente
lo va a seguir se sienten identificados
y ya habló habló el este tipo de por mi
experiencia siguiendo todo esto sí hay
toda esta gente que si los presidentes
como como en su momento Chávez fidelga
No ya mucho tiempo pero pero en este
caso López Obrador viene siendo lo mismo
decir partidos tradicionales no
cumplieron y y llegó alguien con un
discurso que se siente identificado con
la gente y ya todo y Francisco su
opinión sobre este tema y la proyección
que se puede hacer de lo que resta de
tiempo en el mandato para el presidente
López Obrador allí en México
bueno López Obrador creo que si se ha
despolarización él es uno principal
hace hace muchas este digamos ataques a
la oposición al tema de la Reforma que
quiere ser el Instituto Nacional
electoral también entonces el mismo
alimenta la polarización Lamentablemente
ahora Qué puede pasar de Qué puede pasar
de aquí al final de su término Bueno yo
creo que
va a depender que se llama este que sí
digamos que mantenga su popularidad
porque efectivamente hay que reconocer
que es un presidente popular ha bajado
algo no Pero sigue manteniendo cierta
popularidad y ver cómo maneja también el
tema económico y de la de la seguridad
no que siguen siendo un problema todavía
sin sin resolver Más allá de una pequeña
revolución eventualmente con una cifra
de homicidios Pero sigue siendo un
problema sin resolver en México
sigue siendo una de las deudas
pendientes y es una de las de los
aspectos que le cobra la oposición
todavía al presidente destacado también
esta semana lo vimos en diferentes
imágenes a los ciudadanos ucranianos
luchar contra las bajísimas temperaturas
que se están registrando en ese país y
eso que el invierno todavía no ha
comenzado en Europa situación que deben
enfrentar con un deficiente servicio de
gas de calefacción y de Electricidad
recordemos que los constantes bombardeos
de las tropas rusas han afectado la
infraestructura eléctrica del país
algunos ciudadanos han sido evacuados de
ciudades Como por ejemplo kiev y de la
recientemente recuperada ciudad de
gersón en el sur del país de otra parte
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden afirmó que está listo para
conversar con el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin desde el kremlin dijeron
que no estaban las condiciones adecuadas
para iniciar un diálogo entre las partes
le doy la palabra a Juan en mi compañero
acá en el estudio colega periodista que
justamente estuvo en hasta hace algunas
semanas estuvo en la región del donbas y
puede hablar de primera mano de la
situación que se está viviendo allí pues
que no ha cambiado mucho a lo que pasó
esta semana la situación eléctrica con
el invierno empezando Las bajas
temperaturas y los ucranianos en una
lucha por sobrevivir prácticamente
Sí bueno yo estuve cinco semanas en la
zona del donbas entre la ciudad estuvo
en Bad Moore que una de las que están
ahorita con fuerte ataque
entre entre esa pelea este si la gente
se Estaba preparando para para para el
invierno yo vi mucha gente recogiendo
leña buscando leña y acumulando leñas
dentro del apartamento no del
apartamento sino en el building en la
residencia en los pasillos la gente muy
preocupada porque en ese momento tomó la
decisión Rusia de exactamente ese día y
uno de esos días tomó la decisión de
cortar el gas a Europa y y sale salía
Ucrania por supuesto
afecta de todo esto eh la gente está muy
preocupada en las noches no se ve luz
por ningún lado eh tú estás en las
noches y es una ciudad y es totalmente
oscura dentro de alguna otra casa hay
algunas plantas o si escuchas si hay un
poco de luz pero la gente Trata de no
mantenerlo las luces encendidas hay
muchos ataques misiles en la madrugadas
del lado hacia la zona de las ciudades
batmund y
lo siente Y ves la gente en algún
momento cuando ya el ejército ucraniano
comenzó con la ofensiva que tomaron a
varias ciudades entre esas este
Perdón
que fue la primera que yo estuve en la
primera ciudad estuve en ese en ese en
el día que al día siguiente que que
tomaron que tomaron la ciudad otra vez
los soldados cutáneanos
no hay luz no hay agua no hay nada la
preocupada la gente buscando una
esperanza algo OK Y sí se siente y el
invierno el invierno pues va a entrar
muy fuerte No si se nota yo creo que que
una de las imágenes que vamos a lograr
que vamos a ver en algún momento y va a
ser muy malo es que es una ciudad es un
todo lo que es Bad Moore la zona de esa
zona quedó de mucha gente mayor y y
había mucha gente mayor que que no tiene
que no tiene ningún tipo de defensa yo
creo que van mucho lamentable mucho van
a fallecer este por por la Nevada por el
frío de Las bajas temperaturas Francisco
su opinión de la situación de que se
está viviendo en Ucrania y que no tiene
solución en el corto plazo Pese a que el
gobierno ucraniano Está tratando de
restablecer el servicio de gas y el
servicio eléctrico para que las personas
puedan estar un poco más abrigadas en
sus viviendas
Sí yo creo que eso puede ser considerado
como un crimen de lesa humanidad no como
de varias personas están diciendo no que
el hecho de hacer que la la población
muera de frío no tenga calefacción
incluso pueda tener difícil acceso al
agua es puede calificar como un crimen
en esa humanidad Hasta qué punto eso
puede digamos quebrar a los ucranianos y
uno se refiere a lo que pasó en la
Segunda Guerra Mundial donde los
bombarderos masivos por ejemplo contra
Alemania no surgieron el efecto que
esperaban los aliados uno puede pensar
que eso no va a tener mucho resultado en
ese sentido Pero evidentemente los
ucranianos van a sufrir no van a sufrir
este por estos por estos bombarderos Y
ahí se va a ver pues toda esta bueno
seguramente muchos van a van a ser
evacuados eventualmente Pero también
depende un poco de la crudeza del
Invierno no porque es verdad ya ha
empezado pero quién sabe con esto el
calentamiento global eventualmente sale
un invierno que no que no sea
duro en fin habrá que verlo en las
próximas semanas ya veremos Cómo se
desarrolla Y eso que el invierno todavía
no ha comenzado Perlas sus impresiones
y efectivamente coincido con todos
creo que vamos a ver ahora si esta
crisis de falta de Electricidad se va a
prolongar para los ucranianos
desafortunadamente van a los ciudadanos
van a seguir siendo los que van a seguir
pagando las consecuencias de esta guerra
Y bueno pues A ver vamos a ver qué cómo
pueden reaccionar algunos países más
allá de la Unión Europea porque pues
también la Unión Europea se tiene que
preparar para para este invierno y bueno
a ver es el que puede negociar fuera de
la Unión Europea para que pueda tener
apoyo para sus ciudadanos
lo que podemos decir ahora es que hay
incertidumbre en el futuro de este
conflicto en Ucrania y el futuro también
de la Unión Europea como lo dice Perla
porque ellos también están enfrentando
una crisis energética
y haciendo frente a estas bajas
temperaturas pasamos la página otro tema
destacado de la semana vimos nutridas
manifestaciones en China la semana
pasada contra la política de cero covid
los ciudadanos están ya agotados de las
restricciones de los confinamientos y de
la represión de la policía y también el
alto impacto que tiene en la economía
los cierres por la detección de los
casos mientras que en China se mantienen
estas rigurosas restricciones el mundo
entero pues prácticamente ya regresó a
la normalidad Lo cierto es que algo de
razón debe tener china porque los casos
de contagio de covid-19 están en aumento
en varios países del Mundo incluso Hay
nuevas variantes que ya están circulando
vamos a nuestra región por ejemplo en
Perú están en alerta por el aumento de
los casos allá el Ministerio de salud
afirmó que cerca de 8 millones de
personas todavía todavía no han recibido
la cuarta dosis de vacunación y ya están
empezando a ver un aumento de los casos
en Argentina han presentado tres semanas
consecutivas de aumento de casos un
crecimiento del 50.4% las autoridades
también indicaron que van a tener que
tomar medidas al respecto y en Colombia
en solamente en una semana fueron
reportados
3.252 nuevos casos ya fue decretado por
parte de las autoridades el uso de El
tapabocas en los sitios donde haya mucha
concentración de personas o en sitios
cerrados prácticamente estamos dando
pasos hacia atrás Perla su opinión el
covid nuevamente haciendo presencia Tal
parece que esto estamos viviendo un déjà
Vu
sí Exacto Santiago este año creo que no
va a ser la excepción a comparación del
año anterior justo se vaticinaba no En
la temporada invernal Diciembre enero
que van a subir los casos Y bueno pues
las tendencias indican que este año se
va a repetir
los países ahora también otra vez
nuevamente se tienen que brindar con
esta parte de las vacunas en México por
ejemplo el presidente destacaba que se
logró una buena cobertura pero más en la
población mayor y con una sola vacuna y
pues vamos a ver otra vez
Cómo enfrentan cada uno de los países
esta temporada y bueno a ver qué sale Y
si no afecta otra vez la inflación y
otras cosas no que venimos arrastrando
con este conflicto de Ucrania
Francisco su opinión allí en Perú Cómo
están las cosas
bueno Sí precisamente ya oficialmente
estamos en quinta ola no y se está
yo Por ejemplo tú sabes mascarilla no
cuando voy a sitios cerrados Todavía no
se ha adoptado la decisión oficial sí
hacer obligatorio esa medida yo por lo
menos ya la estoy haciendo
sea por ejemplo los hospitales de la el
hospital de la seguridad social ya las
cámaras las cámaras ya están todas
llenas no por ejemplo esos son claro
signo y claro felizmente esta nueva
versión es menos letal que la anterior
además la mayoría de la gente ya está
vacunada no De todas maneras
efectivamente sí está hay que tener
cuidado porque hay gente que le puede
agarrar más fuerte que otra y además
porque también sabes que el efecto del
virus largo podría digamos potenciarse
con una nueva un nuevo contagio no pero
sí ya estamos en quinta ola oficialmente
y aquí en el estudio Juan impresiones
bueno en Ucrania imagínense haciendo uno
frente a una guerra y en medio de una
pandemia y ahora le toca usted regresar
a latinoamérica y aquí la situación
tampoco mejora no Bueno ya ayer
casualidad en la redacción en la
redacción le comenté que que ella siento
que vamos a volver otra vez a empezar a
buscar nuestras imágenes como Colombia
ahora va a empezar otra vez a tomar
medidas Porque ya llevo días observando
esto lo de la pandemia digo bueno en
cualquier momento no va a empezar a
tocar este hacer otra vez las imágenes
para el mundo mostrar
en Europa nadie nadie usa tapabocas yo
estuve más de un mes en Europa después
de Ucrania estuve en otros lugares y
olvídate eso no existe y tapabocas no
existe ahora llegando acá Ya nos tocará
otra vez empezar a hacer ese déjà Vu
otra vez hacer todas estas imágenes para
mostrar a la gente cómo Cuáles son las
nuevas medidas No porque yo creo que si
van a seguir aumentando y van a tomar
las medidas sí va a tocar a tomar
medidas picos que saturan los sistemas
de salud Lo importante es seguirse
cuidando creo que ya aprendimos la
lección ya sabemos cómo tiene que ser el
uso del tapabocas el saludo del
distanciamiento Ya se nos volvieron
reglas básicas Simplemente hay que
refrescarlas y bueno a lo mejor eso
ayude un poco para mitigar el impacto de
esta ola para el cierre porque ya me
quedan pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa Tenemos que hablar obviamente
de fútbol Tenemos que hablar de la Copa
del Mundo Qatar 2022 Tuvimos una semana
con resultados que nos dejaron
sorprendidos a más de uno la cuota
latinoamericana se redujo
considerablemente con esa eliminación de
Costa Rica y Perla Lamentablemente
México se queda por fuera argentina se
revitalizó triunfó y pasó a la ronda de
grupos mientras que unos de Los
favoritos alemán y Bélgica Pues también
se quedaron por fuera sorpresivamente
nadie se lo esperaba nadie lo veía venir
Japón y Marruecos pasaron y de muy buena
forma a la siguiente fase comienzo con
Perla para que nos cuente sobre esa
decepción de la Selección Mexicana veía
medios Donde había intensos debates
sobre sobre el desempeño de la selección
allí en México los Mexicanos lo han
tomado de una manera bastante fría
esta salida de la selección
Exacto justo dijiste la palabra causó
gran decepción de que el equipo la
selección mexicana no haya pasado en
esta fase de grupo
se echa mucho la culpa tanto a la
alineación y Bueno pues también la
renuncia del director técnico no que
pasara lo que pasara en este tercer
partido de todos modos iba a renunciar y
pues dejan traer mucho lo que tú dijiste
los medios pues se fueron contra John de
Luisa que es el presidente de la
federación mexicana de fútbol que
pidieron su renuncia Pero dijo que no se
va y bueno este pues deja este gran
debate no si la Selección Mexicana es
más un negocio o realmente una
selección que juega fútbol
ese debate importante allí para los
mexicanos Francisco Bueno pero no está
pero usted quién le estaba haciendo
fuerza a alguno de sus favoritos se se
fue en esta primera ronda de grupos
bueno
básicamente por los países sudamericanos
no me da gusto que Argentina después de
ese inicial haya podido avanzar por la
verdad por Messi Estoy entre muchos
quisieran que Argentina bueno Brasil
también no pero hay una simpatía
especial por Messi digamos para que él
pueda eventualmente levantar la copa del
mundo no así que me da gusto eso pero en
general bueno muchas sorpresas no esto
de que que haya sido eliminada Alemania
por si alguna vez consecutiva por cierto
y verá Japón y Corea del Sur es
simpático otros países que finalmente
también están o como como Marruecos
también interesante que esos países
están surgiendo no muy interesante Sí ha
sido un mundial completamente inesperado
yo debo decir también que la mente la el
retiro de Uruguay Pues que ya se quedó
por fuera Era uno de esos equipos a los
que le estaba haciendo un poco de fuerza
creo que ahora me concentraré en
Portugal usted tiene algún favorito Juan
Uy
siempre lo voy por los equipos de
nuestra región en este caso también por
México le iba porque viví un tiempo en
México y me y sentía mucho afecto por
México pero ahora nos queda solamente
Argentina y Brasil alguno de los dos que
le vaya bien perfecto que les vaya bien
esa es la cuota latinoamericana Brasil
es un gran opcionado para ganar este año
la copa la verdad lo está haciendo
bastante bien pero bueno mis afectos en
este caso van también Portugal así como
usted vive México Yo viví en Portugal
Entonces es una relación más de de gusto
ya vamos terminando el programa de a
modo de conclusión quiero preguntarles a
Qué temas les van a estar poniendo la
lupa a la siguiente semana que tema
Tienen en remojo en sus redacciones en
sus artículos en sus investigaciones
para para la próxima semana Juan acá en
el estudio bueno próxima semana seguimos
con su cobits a ver que cómo va este
posible de ahí Ayer hoy esta mañana
perdón de una posible visita del
presidente amlo a Colombia todavía no
tenemos fecha a ver para empezar a hacer
esa agenda de cobertura y
y también algo de
la posible ese famoso puente que trajo
problema entre Colombia y Venezuela en
su momento que puede estar empezando a
funcionar a partir el primero de de
enero el 1 de enero entonces ahí estamos
haciendo agenda apenas agenda para ese
para esos temas Francisco Cuál es su
agenda para la próxima semana
bueno la agenda
digamos
humanidad contra los rusos y contra
Putin y los demás y también por el
crimen de agresión es un tema que
quisiera tocar en el programa que es
diario pero hay unos temas que son
digamos este no de actualidad inmediata
sí temas un poco más fríos de la agenda
y después Bueno un poco lo que está
ocurriendo América Latina no hay una
presión adicional respecto del fútbol me
había olvidado otro país al que yo apoyo
nacionalidad
Claro claro
y Perla para el cierre del programa
cuáles son sus temas
Pues justo esta semana la comparecencia
de Pedro Castillo en su tercer debate de
moción de censura y tal vez la previa de
la alianza del Pacífico no que también
ahí fue recorrida por México a Perú sí
tema importante también estaremos
poniéndole la lupa perla a ese tema de
la alianza del Pacífico Pues a los tres
les agradezco mucho por haber estado
aquí con nosotros y haber conversado acá
de manera un poco más relajada sobre
estos temas de la actualidad
internacional es todo por el momento la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Keyla maestra y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Lina Guzmán
ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales Gracias por estar con nosotros
[Música]